друзі Всіх вітаю це догосп як завжди він
відбувається в січні всесвітній
економічний форум і вдруге відбувається
без росіян в 2022 році після пандемії
девушки економічної форум проходив у
травні і вже не було російського
русского дома так званого не було
російського бізнесу російського
олігархату Ну і звичайно зараз так само
довгос проходить без росіян але дуже
важливо щоб росіяни зникли так само з
інших експерт життя цивілізованих країн
власне тема України безумовно
залишається однією з ключових і на всіх
дискусійних майданчиках всесвітнього
форуму і на тих заходах які проходять
цей час в давосі паралельно зокрема в
українському домі який є одним із
магнітів цьогорічного давосу приймає
дуже багато гостей з усіх країн світу і
власне ключові тренди цьогорічного
очевидно що війна
в Україні російська агресія вона впливає
сьогодні на всі сфери економічного
соціального життя гуманітарну сферу
Європи і світу і власне немає такої
дискусії де би не обговорювалися війна
не задавались питання як зупинити цю
болю і що потрібно робити очевидно що
українська делегація представлена тут і
депутатами і урядовцями і експертами
займає одну позицію що Росія має бути
справедливо покарана Росія має принести
повну відповідальність за агресію і мова
йде не тільки про Путіна мова іде про
росіяни які підтримують цю війну між
звичайно про російський бізнес А який цю
війну фінансує і тому дуже важливо щоб
росіяни були не лише в давосі А щоб
все-таки досягли ми таких санкцій
цивілізованого світу як повне ембарго на
російській енергоносії тому що поки що
російські енергоносії вони фінансують цю
війну а дуже важливо щоб війна не
затягувалася Путін мав такий план
спочатку рік тому близький його швидкого
потім не реалізувався цей сценарій і
зараз він ставить на таку дуже затяжну
війну на договірну він на виснаження цей
сценарій грає на Росії тому дуже важливо
не дати можливості жодної Путіну
заморозити конфлікт щоб ця війна тривала
довго і для того щоби допомогти
Українській армії якомога швидше
подолати ворога потрібно більше зброї
зброї і зброї власне тема посилено
постачання України зброї звучала під час
всіх панелей До речі журналісти і
український іноземні а в усіх своїх
питаннях які адресували до сестри
дивіться які присутні тут задавали
питання про танки про системи
протиповітряної оборони про ваш
кортилерію яку потрібно поставляти в
Україні зокрема таке питання зада
канцлер у Німеччини Олег кошульцю не
було прямої відповіді але все-таки всім
Ми сподіваємося на позитивні сигнали які
мають отримати Україна
що світу вже усвідомлює важливість
вчитися в самої Україною українською
армії яка виявила здатність протистояти
одні з найбільших найбільш жорстоких
армій світу Ну і паралельно От коли
відбувається давоз вийшла
заява генріке санжара який вперше Да там
переглянув свої погляди щодо України в
НАТО і сказав що вважає він таким
правильним адекватною відповідь на
російську агресію це все-таки членства
України в НАТО ця стаття держ дуже
широко ця заява обговорюється
наша позиція що саме так цьогорічний
вільності має бути таким важливим для
України ми маємо почути дійсно такий
сильний сигнал щодо членства України в
НАТО і очевидно що як завжди назовні
українська делегація працює ну єдиною
командою єдиним фронтом для того щоб
посилити міжнародну підтримку України як
більше зброї яка має ти не таким
маленьким джерельцем там однієї там
чайної ложечкою до обіду а просто
поставлятися в тих обсягах які сьогодні
потрібні збройним силам України Щоб
протистояти агресії і мати можливість
здійснювати Контрнаступ і звичайно
санкції
доводь без росіян це прекрасна але наша
мета - це Міжнародний кримінальний
трибунал міжнародний трибунал де має
бути притягнуто до відповідальності і
Путіна і всього банку ну і ще раз
наголошуємо що відповідальність війну
настане тільки Путін кожен російський
журналіст який підтримував агресію кожен
росіянин який голосує за Путіна кожен
хто взагалі вважає що Україна - це така
територія впливу Російської Федерації
підтримує цю війну має понести
відповідальність починаючи від е-е
безвізу
тобто не виїзду з Росії в цивілізованій
країні і закінчуючи Звичайно виплатами
репарацій що одна тема важлива яка
звучала на багатьох майданчиках
вдалося це майбутнє відбудова у своєму
України очевидно що тут Україна буде
розраховувати на допомогу наших західних
партнерів очевидно що всі гроші які
мають бути вилучені заарештовані
російські активи мають піти на відбудову
але наші партнери дуже чітко відзначають
що ці відбудова має відбуватися прозоро
і про важливу роль і міжнародних
організацій і донорів і в моніторингу
цих коштів особливу роль парламенту
парламент сьогодні вилучений по суті
багатьох процесів в яких моніторингових
і от тут потрібно повернути цю таку
важливу моніторингову контролюючу роль
парламенту наша позиція нашої політичної
сили яка
вдалося цього року є трохи снігу не так
багато як завжди От і коли ти бачиш не
вдалося радієш йому тому що
сніг це згадуєш про те жахіття яке
відбувається в Україні і ті що ж це що
цього року в нас зима Да не така холодна
як могла би бути тому що нам треба її
пережити вистояти вижити в першу чергу
нашим збройним силам України і зробити
все для того щоби
якнайшвидше настала перемога для цього
треба працювати з нашими партнерами і
разом рухатись до цього І от вдалося
працює багато таких справжних друзів і
лобістів України зокрема оберіг Джонсон
він сьогодні не прем'єр-міністр але дуже
харизматичний безумовно політик який
чітко сказав що фокусуватися світу
сьогодні треба не на Путіні З ним все
зрозуміло його чекає трибунал а на
Україні як допомогти Україні а допомогти
можна тільки в один спосіб зброя зброя і
ще раз зброя над цим треба працювати
дякую